cancel culture is their real-world
cudgel to enforce their censorship
they need the far leftists to punch you
in the teeth when you challenge them
sorry i had to say this it almost feels
like
there is an ai consciousness forming
in all of this big text censorship
inadvertently and it is
and and people like antifa are being
manipulated into being the enforcers
in the real world where the ai can't
actually reach
i'm not saying there's an actual
conscious entity going like i must
control humanity
i'm saying that we are creating this big
network system
that inadvertently has created enforcers
in the real world and they allow it well
it's a symbiotic relationship because
antifa and that sympathize and big tech
train the algorithms
the algorithms then enforce what antifa
want them to enforce more efficient more
efficiently than they can
well it's it's listen
why is it that a black man can go out in
san francisco and say censorship is bad
and a white anti-fuck screaming n word
can knock his teeth out
and the media doesn't freak out over
that it was acceptable
in this weird this weird algorithmic
universe they've created
the ai that they built and their
manipulation because
it's human beings the end of the day
can't get into your home and they can't
get on that stage with you to stop you
they can't censor you when you have a
constitutional right to speak
but they can inflame some antifa people
allow them to organize violent riots and
show up to your home
and punch you in the face and knock your
teeth out then you go to that guy's
house i'm just saying
they've been going to people's houses so
they really need cancer culture
to scare people into adhering to the
manipulations that they want
and they really really need antifa to
knock people out
otherwise what is what what does the
enforcement actually mean in the real
world when people defy you
they want to end the defiance in the
physical realm they'll punch you in the
face
they can already end the defiance in the
digital world by just banning you and
nuking you
so they've got their enforcers yeah and
the enforcers are allowed to operate on
these platforms i was talking to ryan
with impunity i was talking to ryan
hartwig he's a facebook whistleblower
oh yeah he's great yeah he's awesome and
uh you know you know that he was a
facebook content moderator he he was
told he was you know
told by his superiors don't categorize
antifa as a hate organization
so there you have it another another
another smoking gun to a long list of
smoking guns you know you know what i
wish like would be awesome
there's like some you know 70 year old
dude who like owns and runs all of the
he's got a big investor in all these
companies and he's sitting in a room and
it was like 1977 when he
accidentally invented a sentient
computer that's telling him what to do
and then he's going and giving his
underlings orders like that'd be a great
a great movie
unfortunately reality is actually
scarier than that it's human beings
and they're knocking dominoes over not
realizing what they're building around
them
and it's getting scarier domino goes all
the way back around and then hits him in
the back
oh definitely yeah so like if you look
at jack dorsey for instance
like that dude gave what would he give
like 10 million dollars was it to ibram
these people are it's it's human
centipede but like
in you you've seen the movie human
centipede you guys aren't uh i can't say
i have no i've heard it for a time
you know what it's about i'm aware of
its notoriety yeah yeah you know what
it's about
so a mad scientist sews uh a group of
people's mouths to each other's anuses
and creates this big
long human centipede sounds like a
horror movie it is a horror movie it is
a horror movie
yeah and so imagine that but imagine
they're connected in a big circle and
that's what it is
so jack dorsey creates a platform where
he lets the left run rampant
and then eventually the whole political
world is inflated with this in psychotic
far left ideology that he allowed
and then it infects his own brain and
then he gives money to it
a guy calling for racial segregation he
gives money to him
he's created this world where it's
literally he's he's encouraging people
to make
sludge and refuse and then he's
accidentally eating it
and corrupting his own mind and body
yeah and that money eventually comes
back to pressure twitter to censor
someone yeah yep
abraham likes candy yes absolutely yeah
well
then the democrats believe it all too
and the republicans
are not so much i wonder why that is
why you know when we look at the pew
research thing where it shows the
democrats moving very far left why the
republicans have stayed
very much where they are even with trump
and the rhetoric and
cancel culture and all that stuff i
think it's because i think jonathan
height talks about this you know he's
the uh
psychologist who does all this research
about the roots of our political beliefs
he mentions you know conservatives are
quite good at understanding liberals
often because you know
they were former liberals but liberals
are terrible at understanding
conservatives so this is this is why i
think trump still has a fighting chance
we have all this censorship
we have all this propaganda but because
liberals don't understand conservatives
very well
don't understand you know normal
non-liberal people very well a lot of
the propaganda is just
bad well so what i think is happening is
there's there's another chart that i'd
love to share where it shows
moderates most sixty percent of the
moderate news diet is
liberal and thirty percent is
conservative or it's like 66 to 33.
conservatives is the other way around
it's 66 percent conservative and 33
liberal liberals only consume liberal
news
so i think one of the things we saw with
gallup recently is that if you compare
party affiliation from their latest data
set in september to 2016
democrats went from a d plus five
advantage to an r
plus one advantage that's a huge swing
people are leaving the democratic party
and it's because i always hear it
they started researching on their own
yep the people who are in these videos
screaming like lunatics
they're not doing any research at all
they're just reading this shocking story
someone sent them they go what's
happening
they're crying and screaming the rest of
us we see it and we go
let me check that i don't know about
that oh that wasn't true or oh oh that
was true
the reason why biden is a sort of a
strong candidate for the democrats
you know stronger than the alternatives
is for the same reasons that the
liberals would never imagine
it's precisely because he's an old blue
or seems to be just a friendly old blue
collar guy
who's not too extreme that's the image
he projects it's not what he actually is
right but is the image he projects
democrats and liberals do not consider
that to be an advantage they probably
think that's a huge weakness actually
that's probably why
the only reason why trump isn't actually
ahead in many of these polls yep it's
because biden seems
so moderate and offensive to so many i
think the polls are wrong i think
the the the threats of violence the
screaming banshees on on social media
has scared people
and there was uh this research i've
cited quite a bit in the past couple
weeks because we're getting close to the
election showing that 10 percent of
uh trump voters will lie about who
they're voting for
so oh yeah 100 but think about that
that's the wild card you don't
you don't know how many people are going
to turn out for trump because they've
been so intimidated
you look at this early voting right now
and a lot of states it's
it's below 10 for democrats democrats
are supposed to be way way above
republicans
in early and absentee voting and in ohio
today republicans were winning
the other day michigan michigan
republicans were winning but switched
back
you know democrats took a bump so
there's a lot of states where democrats
should have a massive advantage and they
only have a tiny advantage or a
moderate advantage suggesting they're
not they're they're underperforming
dude if trump wins are we gonna have to
deal with this
again all this nonsense and the
screaming it'll be worse if trump loses
it will be worse if he loses it'll be
worse he wins which i hope he will
or do we have to deal with these
screaming offense women in the car or
whoever
screaming young people uneducated people
that are freaking out yes
why why why won't people just chill out
and build something they're they because
they're
they're addicted and they're on facebook
and facebook is
beating them over the head and screaming
in their faces
and they're not smart enough to do a
google search so we need a unified enemy
and maybe it can be the tech oligopolies
you'd think covet would have been that
but no you can't do it because it's a
you can't see it you can't target
someone or something it's too
too amorphous but like no they're
corporations there are some leftists who
get it i mean
the gravel institute which is very very
far left yeah put out a video recently
criticizing the tech giants for their
control over information
uh tulsi gabbard gets it she's talked
about this a lot that's come on
breitbart news radio and talked about it
so she's happy to work across the aisle
um and i think especially the anti-war
left as
you said tim they're getting censored as
well so there's some recognition in some
parts of the left
that big tech the power of big tech
giants is a problem
uh the question is will that ever gain
momentum because you know
for the left now it's all about freak
that the the way to gain followers on
the left is to freak out about trump
to freak out about so-called hate speech
demand even more censorship
so um if i think i think if trump wins
and and republicans don't get the senate
or the house
trumps out they'll impeach him instantly
they're going to pack the courts
they're going to add five or you know
seven more justices to completely
overrule
whatever's there they are going to
fundamentally dismantle and destroy
this country there's already an article
that says abolish the constitution
no joke straight up it's from the new
republic not some fringe sites the new
republic it's a prominent leftist
website saying
abolish the constitution they are they
are not slowing down they are speeding
up and appeasement
doesn't work when when they say we don't
really want to just get rid of all the
cops we're talking about defunding
then the new york times publishes yes we
mean abolish the police
straight up then when you start saying
okay we'll give a little bit
they've defunded i think like 160
departments around the country
yes to some to varying degrees some very
very large numbers some smaller numbers
and then does the left say good now we
can have a conversation of what to do no
now they say great the next thing we
want to abolish is the constitution
so they're planting the seeds because
they will never stop
pulling if joe biden wins unless
so look even if the republicans win
everything then what are they going to
do
what are they going to do nothing
they're going to beg the new york times
to call them cool
will you call me cool and write a cool
update about me no you're a fascist oh
i'm sorry i'll do whatever you say
now you've you've got a mix of many of
these you know uh you've got people on
the right libertarian
right and conservatives being like we
should interfere in the free speech of
these big tech companies
we should let them control the politics
of this country and just run us out of
office permanently
if trump and republicans win there is a
chance that right now with trump with
his hand on the cliff
holding up everybody else can pull us up
and slowly start to push back
trump banning critical race theory was a
really good example of this
all of a sudden we started hearing
stories from people on twitter i lost my
job my company canceled my you know
our our contracts and everything it's
over i can't believe i went to school
for this there was one really funny one
where a person was like i went to school
for
you know five years learning about
diversity and inclusivity and inclusion
and now trump's banned it and i'm
completely out of job and don't what i'm
gonna do
that's trump getting rid of this crazy
psychotic behavior
if biden wins and the democrats take
over then you are going to live
in an algorithmically manipulated
universe where republicans will probably
never win again
they'll pack the courts it will be
listen it's not going to be this utopia
that people on the left think it is
it's not going to be skittles and candy
canes and rainbows and universal
healthcare
it's going to be hitler in a bikini with
a female body dancing
doing tai chi with the incredible hulk
while someone sings a nursery rhyme
that's a real video that was
a that was a mash-up because a computer
algorithm was trying to find things that
people liked
and it mashed them all together so weird
and it created this insane
the incredible hulk with hitler but
hitler has the body of a woman in a
bikini and it's doing tai chi
and then they're singing a nursery rhyme
so that's algorithmic reality
and if the democrats win and they're
falling victim to all this that's what
we're gonna get
biden will certainly this is like
there's a very clear choice is like do
you want digital dystopia or do you want
some chance at getting back our online
freedom
uh biden will absolutely use the federal
government to pressure tech companies
even more
to do even more censorship um yep
it's really amazing how the internet has
changed because the internet as it
existed before 2015 was actually
unprecedented in human history the
amount of free speech we all had
never before could just you have a
device turn it on reach a global
audience that was new
uh but it's now been entirely flipped on
its head and controlled by these
now a handful of corporations get to
control political discourse not just in
america
but all around the world heartwood is
going to be with you guys shortly i was
talking about how he was
moderating political speech in mexico
and venezuela and canada all these
countries that's foreign election
interference right there that's the
border
it's gone from unprecedented freedom not
just to back to the status quo but
beyond that to unprecedented tyranny so
that's where we're at right now and i'll
get worse
under biden let's talk about one more
thing uh this will sound like a massive
tangent but it isn't
um the roman empire collapsed
because or collapsed into dictatorship
because people
the senate became corrupt politicians
became corrupt and people turned to
powerful
strong men and said we're really seeing
that because as you said republican
senators
a great many of them will do nothing to
protect ordinary people from these tech
giants
the only entity in the world perhaps
today doing that is the trump
administration
they're the ones who petitioned the fcc
got the fcc to come out and say okay yes
we'll do something on section 230.
they're the ones who appointed nate
simmington to the fcc a guy who's a
social media who got rid of the old guy
who was uh skeptical about reigning in
tech censorship
so really the american executive branch
is the only branch of government that
might actually do something
didn't the roman empire last a thousand
years some uh oh yeah i mean hell
rome under the caesars was not
particularly a bad place to live but it
was like
a thousand years we made it what 240
something yeah
250. the republic was like 400 years and
then the
empire took over for about 300 or 400
more and then it
split into two empires uh the eastern
empire and the western empire the
eastern empire became the byzantine
empire
but you see the parallel where you know
politicians no longer defend the
entrance of the people
and only the executive branch does so
what's the answer well you have to give
more power to the executive branch
i don't like that idea what do you guys
think about net neutrality
i don't know i remember it was huge
total total uh play on words by the uh
by the liberals
can you define it so it was essentially
a law that defined
uh well an executive action by the
fcc by obama's fcc that made isps
internet service providers comcast
verizon
common carriers so they had to you know
treat everyone equally treat everyone
neutrally so
if netflix is using your bandwidth even
if they're using way more of it than any
other
company uh you have to charge them the
same rate so it was really something
that only helped netflix and youtube and
these big video streaming platforms
and the service providers google
facebook all these platforms
so it was basically the edge what's
called in
in the technical fcc language the edge
providers facebook google youtube
versus the service providers verizon
comcast it was a battle between
corporations
and under obama the uh the service
provider
sorry the edge providers facebook google
youtube uh netflix they won that battle
under trump they got rid of it it's not
really about net neutrality
it doesn't force anyone to be
politically neutral
and uh if it does then it was aimed at
the wrong target because the isps
to my knowledge have never actually
censored political speech if you're
going to have net neutrality apply it to
google and youtube
and facebook as well uh because they're
the ones who threaten
the actual neutrality of the internet
they're the ones deciding who gets
so-called throttled 230 reform could
save
the republic if if 230 is clearly
defined which edge of pi should have
done a long time ago
now he's all of a sudden like oh we're
gonna do it okay sure if this happened a
long time ago
and the companies like wikipedia were
were liable for their libel
and twitter had to have strict
moderation policies
then free speech would be allowed debate
would be happening and people would have
the opportunity to actually speak with
each other
a site like mines a startup like mines
would have went under
because we couldn't we only had like
three moderators and
you wouldn't have to moderate that's the
point yeah it would it would mean we
would have to ban
no you wouldn't you'd have to
this is the argument that free market
libertarians made which is the opposite
of that if you moderate
then you're suddenly in publisher
territory uh with microphone issues
no no no you're good oh okay your
headphones might have cut got it got it
yeah um anyway it's the opposite of that
because if you get section 230 reform
the right kind of section 230 reference
i will say you don't want to repeal the
entire that's a bad idea
what you want to say is if you it's very
simple it's so simple i don't know why
more people aren't suggesting this
you simply say if you want to be a
platform if you want to have that legal
immunity
you can't filter legal content
constitutionally protected content on
behalf of your users
you can filter it but only if the user
chooses to filter it so exactly the same
as google's safe search option
but for all types of content so you
would not have to moderate
okay wait so if someone posts something
illegal i have to get it off the site
as a moderator or the site gets sued
because we can't host illegal content
that's true now
that's true right that's yeah that
doesn't change that if
so if you so you're saying if i right
now if you if you moderate
legal content on behalf of the user so
the user doesn't ask you to hide that
from their feed
then you are no longer a platform you
lose section 230 protections
but if you give the user the option to
filter that content say if you make a
hate speech filter
that liberals can turn on or off that's
fine right you just don't do it on
behalf of the user
so right now what's happening is section
230 says
good faith moderation is allowed the
idea was
you can't be responsible for what a user
posts to your website
that's not fair i didn't say it is a
comment so right now
they can moderate against users will but
this would say you're not allowed to
moderate against their will unless they
ask you to moderate for it
right so so they can here's the thing so
free market defenders of the big tech
coming to say first amendment
anyone can uh moderate their property
their
communications platform as much as they
want or you're violating the first
amendment
that's actually true but not every com
while every company has first amendment
rights they don't have these special
section 230 legal immunities
so what you can say is if you want these
special legal immunities that no other
company gets
then you're going to have to behave in a
certain way it's very simple yeah
so right now on mines you have the the
not safe for work
filter right yeah people can turn it off
and just see everything yeah
and so if it's like so one of the
arguments was people need to be able to
these
these sites need to be able to remove
porn or something like let's say you're
a religious
community forum and someone said
spamming porn you'd be able to get rid
of it
so there that that is one of one of the
challenges
in setting these terms and these rules
but the
users have the ability to then say
filter this out for me
and so they can't see it so someone come
in and can post whatever garbage they
want but no one sees it who's actually
participating there there's still
challenges but the general idea is
right now twitter says it is
objectionable if someone says vote trump
therefore will ban them well section 230
says we're allowed to moderate
objectionable content without crossing
the line
that needs to be defined what does that
mean so so the general idea that many
people have had is
you can't remove legal content
if it's a violation of the law like a
call to violence threatening harm
or you know horrifying images or
whatever then they can get rid of that
they have to now
but if it's someone saying vote trump
then you can't touch it yeah also if
that's how the law were
then it would be so much easier for tech
platforms and new platforms like mines
because
you would one you wouldn't have to have
moderators and two you wouldn't
necessarily have to build the filters
yourself what i imagine would happen
would
there be all sorts of third-party
browser extensions
that filter content across the internet
for you so you don't ever want to see
say you don't ever want to see obscene
content on the internet you want to keep
your internet family friendly
i imagine what would happen in this new
uh this new world where tech platforms
can't censor on your behalf is
you'd have browser extensions that
people install and it would filter
your online experience across all worlds
but what would happen is someone would
apply
porn and they wouldn't market explicit
because people just that's how they live
they don't mark their stuff they put it
up and then you have to go in and find
it
and then moderate it or you have to
build an algorithm
well that's a problem now so maybe and
then you can
get complaints that it hasn't been
flagged yet it's well that's a problem
that you have now that's problem that
google has you know so they train
algorithms to recognize that kind of
content and what would happen is you'd
have browser extensions that do the same
thing that have algorithms
that recognize and they you know they
get better and better and they improve
over time with updates
yeah it's time to it's time to in a
sense
scale back the desperate attempts
because what's happening is
you get twitter and facebook saying this
is objectionable and this isn't
and then a bunch of people freak out
saying that's not fair a really good
example of the problem was when i was
talking with with jack dorsey
and i said your rules are inherently
biased and they said no that's not true
and i said you banned people for
misgendering
and they were like so conservatives
don't view the word misgender the same
way you do
your rules are inherently biased you
should not be allowed to do that
imagine this imagine you make a phone
call to your
mom and you're like did you see this
story about you know donald trump doing
a back flip and then click
phone goes off and then you get your
your phone vibrates and it says
you were sharing objectionable
information that wouldn't that would be
insane nobody would like that's a
private phone call
facebook's actually censoring private
messages twitter when it came to the new
york pro story was blocking link sharing
in direct messages this is well beyond
acceptable
behavior it's not good faith i know what
the equivalent is i start off my book
with this the prologue it's a story
about
a guy in uh the 1960s who's writing a
letter on his typewriter the typewriter
stops working says you can't use a
typewriter anymore your last letter was
hate speech
and he tries to call his phone his
friend on the phone the phone operator
says sorry
you said hate speech through the phone
last time can't use it today sorry
you're banned for 10 days
tries to uh go buy a newspaper the new
stand owner says well your favorite
newspaper isn't stopped anymore it was
it was uh publishing disinformation
look at that that would be that would
have been so bizarre to like our
our parents and our grandparents but
we're just accepting it on social media
the exact same i'd like to see them
become utilities big companies like that
once they have a certain amount of users
per day
maybe maybe there's a lot there's a lot
of talk i think simple 230 reform is the
first thing to do
and then so if content goes up it's
objectionable and someone complains
you're liable for it as a
as a platform because no because you're
supposed to make sure that the filter
works and the filter is not doesn't work
objectionable doesn't mean illegal right
but if someone has a filter
and they turn it on they don't want to
see porn but the porn hasn't been
flagged yet and they see it the site can
get sued
no that's not true well if there's 230
things that's not true
right now you're wrong you do not you're
wrong you're wrong there are two there
are two parts of section 230 one which
exempts um companies from lawsuits here
but the removal of content and one
that exempts them for hosting content so
i'm not saying that you should uh
strip immunity from tech platforms
simply for uh for hosting
they need that immunity but it should be
contingent on behaving like a platform
so not moderating content on behalf
right if porn gets posted
and it slips with a filter no that is
that is not a violation of 230.
it is these things happen and the people
can complain
and then the site can fix it but if the
site purposefully takes action that
violates 230 then they
lose their liability protections that's
the way to right to change it yeah
and that's what needs to happen we'll
see if we actually get to that point i
think if we
enlighten people as to what exactly so
they understand what the change will be
that there will be a lot more support
for it
yeah the pro the problem is uh
platform hasn't been properly defined
under the law so we have platforms
behaving like publishers that's what we
want to
but i don't think you know some people
say you know repeal section 230
don't repeal it it's necessary for free
speech on the internet to exist
just reform it so that platforms behave
like platforms can you can you explain
what the difference between a platform
and a publisher
a platform hosts content and a uh a
publisher speech edits
it speaks it edits it chooses what you
see and that's all that's what the
platforms are doing now they're choosing
what people so
listen listen if you post a message
saying you know
screw alum and you post it on a a a
board out in the middle of the
town square i don't sue the board but if
you stand there and scream screw ellen i
say you're the one who spoke
that's the difference twitter is
supposed to be a big
you know community board people can walk
up and put their messages on and walk
away
and you don't complain about the board
because someone put a message on it
that's why you can't sue twitter
the problem is what what twitter has
become
is in order to get in this there's a
gate and when you walk in jack dorsey's
standing there saying
not that one wait what did you say oh
i'm taking that one down and it's like
wait you're curating what people can and
can't say you are effectively speaking
because you're restricting some things
and promoting other things they may
become a publisher more importantly
twitter has begun actually issuing news
statements so there's quite literally on
the town center square it says
the twitter board and jack dorsey is
writing things on it and now we're like
yo
i can sue you for that and they're like
actually you can't
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you